I'll give you phonetically the Asians
okay yes Vietnamese
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
a careful boys today we have Jesus
[Applause]
baby thank you guys man yeah you're
getting a little nasty last time huh you
rip it too hard I'm Teresa dude I
haven't stopped bumping Teresa Tay ever
since dude
fat girl did you guys re-watch that
episode with the music I watched it
I watched it my girl judge me the whole
time they're like do you have to be
gross I was like what are you talking
about
this is me baby you cut it off leave it
in there and [__] cut it off that's
pretty [__] grossful I've never been
to your stand-up shows uh yeah she's but
she's like does she laugh at your job
you know what it is dude she laughs at
the guys that I'm like whack and she's
just like he's funny
is there can you say your names oh dude
this guy named Jason
is it because she knows your jokes
because she's hurt a thousand times no
no no no it's her style is different
than my style even like bro like that's
the worst like Christmas movies and
you're just like this is so who is this
for who's it yeah who is this for it's
for her dude it's for her what are her
favorite movies dude she watches like
comedy movies those is one about the uh
Lindsay Lohan the recent one the
Christmas freaky Fridays not another
recent one that was on Netflix exactly
nobody [__] watched it but it's new
she was just like it was new it was on
Christmas I didn't know she was in a
Christmas movie she's a big long hand
and she hits her head no she just like
watches anything and she wakes up to
someone else now yes
you watched it she wakes up at Santa
Claus yeah dude so she wakes up doesn't
know who she is she falls in love with
the like the guy who's broke was trying
to you know make and she was in love
with the guy with the money you know
typical [__] sounds like you liked it
a little bit it was interesting
I was I was like crying at the end yeah
talk to your heart emotional sure
um but Liz and Lohan always makes me
[__] rock hard so yeah I was like
let's watch it but you still got it
glass is the cheesiest [__] things is
it hard to pick movies with her based
off oh yeah yeah you know I I try
watching like the real like edgy ones
and she's like what like what's the edgy
one like an edgy one like let's say
sicario or something no Pineapple
Express like an easy funny that's edgy
that's edgy too what the [__] she's
like they're just smoking weed and just
you know I'm just like but this is
[__] [__] the craziest funny it's
like yeah but it's like she the ones
like that love actually yeah it's like I
don't know it was rom-coms is she like
friends you know what movies you like
what and I [__] hate it was the one
with the
with um that Siri he falls in love with
Siri
no no
no the comedy one it's called jexy jexy
or Jackson
there's a comedy here's a good movie
her's a great movie yeah I could see how
that came she thought it was a comedy
her was deep yeah it was a I was just
like it was a bummer of a movie I could
see how this can you know be a thing
wait this [__] this yes yes that's the
one dude that's the one jexy she likes
movies like that I watched it and I was
like
I know this is the worst and she was
like I love with Adam Adam DeVine does
she like Adam Sandler movies is he
really yeah based off the cover I can
tell you I'm not gonna like that movie
it's the cheesiest corniest comedy that
you're just but it's sweet I've skipped
that on an airplane it has to have like
a lot like a feel good she loves those
feel good I need someone dying yeah yeah
she need deaths I tried watching like uh
hey she's cool she's in it
somebody but I tried watching like uh
like drug dealer movies with her and
like I love it those are fun oh dude she
doesn't like gangster movies that's a
true story is that into the drug scene
what about Ozarks is she like Breaking
Bad how's Arkansas
she loved Breaking Bad oh what she like
Breaking Bad but then she was like hold
on check this out she's like Breaking
Bad but then at like the last last
season last episode
she was like
um or last season she was like no it's
too dark but that was the best but you
watched the bridge yes yes dude yes
exactly dude the buildup was there we're
ready to go I'm ready to I'm re-watching
this so I'm like dude this last season's
gonna get even better she's like I need
a break it's just too much
oh it's so good when he passes up to
everything dude yes but then she doesn't
want to
it's been a month
okay we like finish this you guys watch
like [__] eight seasons of it but
she's done she's like I'm over it my
wife did that to me oh she would have
wanted it
by that time people should want him to
get away I don't even like a show but
I've watched it that much now I invested
yeah that's like walking dead yeah it's
been dead but I had to keep going you
gotta see what happens right oh so you
were like in it even though you didn't
like it I was just like all right how
long they were still fighting the
governor like what the [__] because you
wanted to see where it would lead right
I needed to finish you're that simple
already yeah I'm In Too Deep Walking
Dead was the one that I was like I
talked so much [__] about it that I just
my pride wouldn't let me yeah why did
you talk [__] about her because I was
like I'm the type that's like if you
like if everybody likes something I'm
like [__] that
yeah I was late on Taylor Swift I'm
barely getting on her right now how
about Game of Thrones how about Game of
Thrones dude the game of you did it
though I was in it when I had cable
and I you know I was a little bit broke
so then I cut it off so I stopped
watching Game of Thrones but I was in it
oh but then I stopped and then things
started getting good you know what I
mean so then I started picking it back
up right right with like the last season
was your lady into it I was like rushing
it she was into it but I wouldn't know
her at the time all right you gotta
admit right now the [__] that you were
like I'm too prideful to watch because I
already invested saying no too much but
you actually like what would it be
what would it be
something that I talked so much [__] and
then you actually like I really liked
it's got to be friends really yeah
Brands I talk so much fun to whack it's
corny I don't get it the writing is
actually really good but then every like
you know I'm on the hotel rooms all the
time like from doing shows I'm on the
road and then it just comes on I'm like
[Laughter]
[__] Ross
gets me every time dude stupid ass Ross
I like that with Seinfeld when I was
younger I thought it was so dumb did you
hate it when The Simpsons was over like
why did you hear the bass guitar you're
like
but now it's so freaking good it's
really good we're just too young to
understand yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
what's what's up what's a young movie I
mean what's the movie that you watch
Young and you watch it now you're like
this movie is so so oh yeah I'll tell
you what that messed me up was hook hook
is hilarious cook is good
you didn't like it as a kid I mean as a
kid you're like you liked it but you
didn't get the all the jokes yeah as an
adult it hits really as an adult when
you watch some of these [__] hits as an
adult you watch these moves you're like
because he's an adult he's an adult in
it so now you're watching it as people
wow it's pretty cool it is it's really
it's a good one dude you'll catch all
the jokes that Robin Williams was saying
like even at the dinner party and stuff
you're like I don't know oh yeah because
as a kid you're only like focusing on
the physical stuff yes yeah like when he
calls him a nearsighted gynecologist
yeah
I got a lawyer it's like dude as a kid
you're like what but now I'm like oh
hilarious not that kind of lawyer yeah
[__] funny all of his jokes hit so
hard now that's true yeah dude [__]
Rufio huh I know that's the matter
everybody loves Rufio did it really yeah
yeah he's always here
roof oh really yeah oh dude I just
started following him on Tick Tock he
kept going like residual checks and I
was like oh yeah yeah he's like 10 cent
checks for hook I tripped out of how
many things he was on I'm like oh yeah
he was in a lot of stuff especially back
then what is he what kind of Asian is he
looking though Filipino Filipino no [__]
oh you're Filipino
do we like Filipinos what's going on
let's decide right now
this guy's at a bunch of [__] too really
not like that I always see you randomly
in like either in credits or on credits
or in the audience you know I was
telling you oh wait that's right so I
was watching a Bill Burr's like a comedy
thing and then uh it panned to the
audience and I was like oh yeah dude
that's a credit dude it's like no no but
you're in some credits too dude that's
[__] crazy you're in just random like
[__] all over what credit is he is I was
making some kids movie or something did
you do some music or oh yeah I did do
yeah what'd you do I do like kids stuff
see who are you dude Ryan's so
mysterious dude the children I love it
it's funny if Ryan uses that as like
you can read the girl over it's what's
special
I was like oh my God he looks yeah
that's me it is who you think it is
real quick
it says my girl gets free tickets to
things like that because she's an
influencer so they always try to get her
to go to sleep I don't get no tickets
like that I'm always like I'm gonna go I
want to go
[Laughter]
yeah dude those influencers get invited
to all kinds I know I try to get him by
this stuff no we don't we don't even get
invited to the regular influencer [__]
we also don't get invited to all the
Asian [__] and the Asians be doing hell
what the Asian Woods go out of their way
tonight they have [__] what is the
[__] what's that one they invite us
sometimes but we always say we're out of
town they got some galators they send us
to the wrong email and then they do the
gala [__] they do the gold house gold
house yeah well we say we're out of town
yeah dude I mean stop inviting
I'll come in town I don't mind but
there's something cool what's what BART
wants to get invited just to tell them
no oh you get up we get off on that you
just want the you just want to feel like
you're a part of it it's gonna be part
of the Asian Community a little bit do
you do a lot of Mexican Community stuff
dude well you know should have buried an
Asia then yeah I get invited to all
kinds of like Mexican things dude do you
perform at Quinceaneras I don't I don't
perform
dude yeah hey dude shoot out the gate
guys
I'm trying to think of all the the
Mexican things I've been to yeah you
think he's a mariachi band or what you
think I'm out here playing the guitar
you think I know Mariachi even though I
do he's like are you one of those guys
El Torito yeah dude any other Mexican
questions you want to ask him no I don't
know
at the party by the way Jack Black it's
a pass bro for doing that oh [__] he's
like yo it should be canceled like for
one for making a great [__] movie
yeah dude dude
and by the way he did cosplay Mexican he
said he was half German there you go oh
that's what he said in the movie
he's not Mexican but he grew up in
Mexico it's like yeah he gets a pass
that happens in real life too
ethnically Mexican wait hold on dude
I've got character go back to you guys
didn't get invited to that whole
premiere of the crazy Rich Asians nope
for like everybody oh wait we did we
went to that one we did oh we're gonna
say oh cool that's pretty coveted I'm
talking about covet after oh okay just
like two years ago you guys off the
guest list huh once we became pro-gun I
think like oh [__] dude pro gun huh
never mind political huh yeah I just
don't think we're big enough no I see
some small ass influencers there
like who yeah Point them out dude what
are their names dude like I don't know
10 000 followers hey
hey any race what race do you think
Chinese did Chinese and they get
canceled you would you play a Chinese
guy oh yeah [__] yeah please play a
Chinese guy dude I will know to write a
movie about like that I go to China and
you were born there yeah yeah I was born
there and I'm just actually
accent
here's your line read it
hungry wait wait hurry up oh
hurry up and buy this guy
you gotta do it come on
you should just be real that's what you
should be I don't know how's he
accidentally it depends on which Asian
you know what okay can I say something
about ages can I say something yeah
it might be a little racist yeah I have
to cut this out let it out let's go you
might agree with you make this part
louder what's with the moans the moans
like there's a lot of yeah oh that might
be like Korean stuff I don't know if
it's created every Asian I met does a
little
Cantonese
[Music]
which Filipino
that's true
and the Japanese is interesting because
there's two I like Japanese either
though you see I like that or I like
that
Sweden
and let me tell you that
and that's my favorite porn by the way
so you watch your mouth
very they're very like
there's only two I'm not supposed to be
here killing themselves
they're so cute
yeah okay so who's who's this guy who's
this because I've been around this guy
and I don't know who the [__] he is or
what he is but he was my neighbor and
he'll go Vietnamese Vietnamese
version of Vietnam are you breathing
that language
and I'm like he was [__] with me I
was like get the [__] out of here he was
[__] his mom and his mom was replied
I'm like oh this is a thing okay this is
the thing this bit is going prettier
[Laughter]
I'm like
no close no Cambodian sounds super
difficult yeah
[Laughter]
but I'm glad you guys dumb it down for
me you know yeah yeah just so you know
very confused pretty accurate yeah it's
pretty good you're kind of you're you're
actually very spot on I would say so so
who's like the elite Asian
who thinks they are or who they oh yeah
who thinks they are is different that's
two different in the Latino world
there's a lot of that too is it Mexicans
or no is it Argentina well argentinians
think they think they are this is world
of One World Cup too oh they think
they're very did win the World Cup
they're they're winner did win though
let me tell you about Argentina's like
love anything they think they're classy
they're better they're like we're white
adjacent yeah they're just very loud
there's also a lot of Nazis that ran
away from Germany and went to so they
are they that they're that's where the
superiority complex white enthusiasts it
makes sense yeah this is true but you
know and but I feel like as far as I in
my opinion I feel like Mexicans are the
ones that are like we're just the most
proud March I think we're still manages
by numbers I think by numbers well it's
a high population I think so I think
like that about if you see the land
world I think it's just like oh there's
a bigger diaspora you're more Mexican
everything is Mexican like if you see a
Latino everybody speaks Spanish they
think oh you're Mexican yeah oh you're
Mexican nobody says orange Argentinian
or girl you think that's only here in
the US or is that everywhere where why I
think I think my opinion is I think
Mexicans have like
is it the Mexican-American complex I
think so I think maybe because like we
just put ourselves out there more and
the people there's a lot more more than
they see like Colombians or like but now
it's changing I think the east coast is
different that bad bunny like now that
bad Bunny's out yeah but I bet the East
Coast Puerto Rico everybody's all about
poor Puerto Ricans are hot
yeah because the East Coast the East
Coast got the Caribbean blacks and the
Mexicans Caribbean Mexicans who's
actually on top
in actuality who's daddy right now
I want to say it's not Costa Ricans
I want to say it's Mexicans do it it
might be right we're just running the
game I think I think we're running the
game because you guys got like Mario
Lopez you got Canelo you got a lot of
people that are like yeah
who else you guys got do you think
Brazil but Colombia like I don't know I
think it's like but do you think Brazil
fall like even though they're Portuguese
speakers are they in the same or they're
like we're Brazilians yeah Brazil's are
kind of weird right right because you're
like are you Latino because they are
Latino right yes but they speak like
mother [__] yeah Portuguese some other
[__] somebody you can catch like a
little bit of Spanish what does
Portuguese sound like
I'm telling you they're women sounds
like city of God
with Asians you would say Korea is the
one that thinks they're on top what's
the one that's really on top right now I
think they actually are on top I think
they manifested that Destiny can I tell
you what it is I think China's emerging
I'm gonna give you my thing my theory
okay I don't know much Jesus Asian thing
but I think my Asian Theory and don't
get mad dude
I think it's I think it's Japanese and
number one whoa I know I know hold on
I'm going by GDP only okay GDP only
Koreans and then Chinese
I want to say my I I want to say it but
what's stopping you but it's Philippines
Chinese oh my God Philippines above
China yeah because of break dancing look
keep it going keep it going I gotta go
dude I gotta go dude this is causing so
much I love the new rankings you don't
hear these above time the reason why is
because I guess I'm here by podcasts of
people I've seen I met a [__]
Discovery I'm meeting Philip that I'm
thinking like oh they're like pretty
badasses yeah if you leave [__]
Pacquiao yeah yeah right what's going on
that's what I'm seeing this is what I'm
seeing I think China number one in China
to me it's I'm scared as [__] China I
don't know what's going on what's going
on yeah dude oh what they're doing over
there dude but hey someone calm down
there everything hey can you come down
foreign